president biden is sending a stark
message to russia and vladimir putin
president biden is announcing the
deployment of more u.s troops to europe
the move is a declaration that russia is
a direct threat and it's part of the
biggest shift in nato defense priority
since the end of the cold war president
putin says his military will respond in
kind to any threats from nato countries
nancy cordes is at the nato summit in
madrid nancy good morning so what else
is nato doing to respond to russia's
invasion of ukraine
well that just for context right now
nato has a rapid response force of about
40 000 troops spread throughout the
continent under this new plan the number
of allied troops on high alert would
grow more than seven fold to 300 000
troops and the u.s would establish its
first permanent base
near the russian border in poland
the new military measures are a
recognition that russian aggression
could continue for some time the u.s
deployments will include two more navy
destroyers to spain two f-35 fighter jet
squadrons to the u.k and an additional
combat brigade to romania we're going to
make up sure that nato is ready to meet
threats from all directions across every
domain land air and the sea president
biden is expected to announce that the
u.s will also give ukraine a
medium-range air defense system known as
naysams
it's capable of shooting down the kind
of cruise missile russia used to strike
a busy shopping mall in central ukraine
earlier this week
but ukrainian president vladimir
zelinsky appearing remotely urged the
nato leaders here to do even more he
said he can't break russia's dominance
without more artillery tanks and armored
vehicles
we need weapon weapons
igor joka is zielinski's deputy chief of
staff what does victory look like for
ukraine what does winning the war mean
bringing back all the ukrainian
territories definitely no other
compromises are possible russian
president vladimir putin denounced
nato's military expansion and the formal
invitation for sweden and finland to
join the western alliance
if nato troops and infrastructure are
deployed to sweden and finland he warned
we will be compelled to create the same
threats to the territory that is now
creating threats for us
president biden is likely to get
questions about all of this at a press
conference he's holding here at the nato
summit this morning it is his final
formal engagement at the summit before
flying home to washington d.c gail
thank you very much nancy cordes
reporting from madrid